(Stream)
"I really want to try to become a pro CS player."
(Casting)
(Stream)
"Have you ever tried looking up, the male pornstars."
"People reported me for that are you serious?
Chat, you can't handle seeing a f*cking d*ck."
(Stream)
As a kid, Jaryd “Summit1G” Lazar saw CS:GO for the first time while hanging around a
card shop.
And the rest is history.
"I used to go to this card shop, and one day I walked in and they had all these computers set up.
They were playing Counter-Strike, and that was the first time I'd ever seen Counter-Strike
and I thought it was the coolest looking f*cking thing."
Summt1G has kept the monichor “1G” from a community forum he was apart of back in
the days of early Counter-Strike.
"Summit was actually a jocker of 1G
But then because the actual 1G club stopped doing like scrimmages."
"Like died at the end of 1.6."
"It was like a scrim team in Counter-Strike called 1G and they brought Summit in at the end,
and I think he just repped it for fun and on his brand people started doing the 1G thing,
and he's like yeah!"
Holding on so tightly to those two archaic characters is just so quintessential Summit.
He’s the brash veteran.
The no nonsense old-head who’s been here since the beginning and isn’t going to change
his ways for anybody.
(Stream)
And that’s why the CS community, the 1G
crew and those who’ve been Twitch fans from
the very beginning, love him so much.
"Been watching you for a long time now, finally can give you some support love you."
"Yo Qutrix thanks man. I appreciate that dude, very much."
Since it’s been possible to stream CS — Summit1G has been doing it.
(Stream)
Summit created his Twitch account on November 30th, 2011 and started streaming regularly
October of 2013.
From the beginning, he’s always been all about the game.
No matter what he’s playing, he’s constantly trying to get better and bringing you along
for the ride.
(Casting)
Summit is widely recognized as one of the first to make it big as a streamer on Twitch
and it’s not too hard to see his influence on the platform with a handful of top streamers
crediting him as one of the reasons they wanted
to get into streaming in the first place.
"And the reason I started streaming, was because of Summit. I was watching Summit play
and back then it was like wordsy, how much he streamed inspired me what not he quit his job.
I was like I wanted to do that."
Even in the early days of Twitch’s mainstream relevancy back in 2015, Summit was drawing
a large audience, even by today’s lofty standards.
In August 2015 he averaged more than 16,000 viewers at a time.
Since then he’s managed to hover around those numbers with outstanding consistency
— peaking at more than 28k in January of
2018.
(Stream)
On stream, Summit’s kind of  just like you and me.
He certainly wears his emotions on his sleeve and he's not afraid to full on tilt-off in front
of thousands of fans.
(Stream)
Games play with our emotions, they pull us in and make us invested in our success.
And nobody embodies that feeling of of being encapsulated more than Summit.
He’s fiery, he appreciates a good meme and well…
"What would you do if there was a child right in front of you."
"I'd punch that kid in his little f*cking teeth."
During the infancy Counter Strike: Global Offensive’s, Summit made the jump from streamer
to competitive player.
He had toyed with the idea of competing as he was beginning to stream but
committed to it in 2015.
"I really wanna try to become a pro CS player."
"And I'm even willing to put in the time to get that done."
He played in tournaments with Torqued and Area 51 Gaming to middle-of-the-pack results,
but to his ever-growing fan base, those results were mostly irrelevant.
(Stream)
In a lot of ways his semi-pro career could never fail — just because of how nicely
it paired with his stream.
He was constantly trying to improve and focus on gameplay — just like his viewers - which
made him more relatable than a lot of pros.
"I'm still gonna obviously be the same streamer, you know I'm still gonna be talking to you guys a bunch,
still gonna be thanking subs, thanking donations, having a chill time."
Think of it as a Twitch reality show where our protagonist Summit has quit his job and
is chasing the professional Counter Strike dream.
And he’s taking his fans along for the ride.
(Casting)
In addition to his ability to balance an urge to compete with a successful stream, Summit
has also been able to successfully juggle multiple games.
Which is something that many streamers struggle with.
Even in those early years Summit played DayZ and Rust along with CS:GO.
(Stream)
As long as he was playing a shooter — people would show up and watch.
Summit’s stream was steady, but his hunger for more competitive success had not subsided.
So in 2016 he gave it another shot — this time with Splyce.
During which, he would compete in the largest event of his pro career: DreamHack Austin in 2016.
(Casting)
Austin was also the site of the most memorable moment of Summit’s professional career.
A play that will go down in Counter-Strike history as one of the game’s biggest fails.
(Casting)
Summit clutches the round for his team, but in retrospect his celebration was a little
premature as he walked directly into the flames of his own Molatov.
Dying and handing over the round to CLG.
As cringy as it may be to watch.
This might just be the most quintessential “Summit” moment.
"Now when you die to a molotov by yourself it's called pullin a Summit."
It’s the perfect intersection of his high skill level and at-times goofy persona.
It’s the type of thing his chat would flame him for on-stream — and he did it in a Pro CS tournament.
"Like when it happened I was like, "Dude my life's over."
Like I can't even step foot, in the world right now. Like I just... My life's over."
And what’s more is that sense that  Summit has owned his mistake.
He’s wielded it, and it could be argued that he’s seen even more success as a streamer because of it.
"Kind of like created a name for myself a little bit."
After his time with Splyce, Summit played with Mythic, a semi-pro CS:GO team filled
with popular streamers.
His time with Mythic allowed him to scratch his itch for competitive play, but also stream
the games live on his channel giving him and his viewers the best of both worlds.
(Casting)
As summer 2017 rolled around, Summit was hit by the same infatuation as almost every other
streamer and gamer in the FPS world — Player Unknown’s Battlegrounds.
(Stream)
PUBG certainly flipped the script on streaming shooters.
The pace of play is perfect and gives streamers ample time to interact with their chat between
games.
(Casting)
The  whole experience is more like a television
show or movie rather than constant gameplay.
(Stream)
Since Battle Royales have blown up, Summit has strayed away from competitive play.
Just as big personalities like Shroud have been able to focus on being professional streamers
rather than professional gamers.
A distinction that has become a lot more clear and plausible since Battle Royales have arrived.
(Stream)
Summit 1G’s an old school gamer.
He’s been around since the humble beginnings of both Twitch and esports.
But even a guy with his feet as cemented into the scene as Summit isn’t immune to hate.
As we saw this year:
(Stream)
Summit took major heat from his fanbase for
his choice to stream Fortnite with controversial Youtube star Jake Paul.
(Stream)
"Bro you're disappointed that a guy is playing a video game.
with another human being that you happen to not like from a YouTube series that you don't watch.
"Alright? Relax."
At first glance, it may seem pretty tame.
A harmless marketing move to collaborate with an incredibly famous person in the biggest
game in the world.
But, this is gaming — where loyalty is everything.
(Stream)
"Ay man feel free, I understand completely."
So now that we’re here, and someone like Summit — the guy who quit his job to become
a streamer years ago — is streaming the new hot game with a millionaire clickbait
enthusiast — his fans really put him on blast.
"If you're gonna look at it from a business perspective, playing with them. It ain't good for you.
like who gives a f*ck how many subs they have."
"Though your channel becomes completely cancer,
and your entire environment and channel becomes garbage."
"You know you're gaming with someone like just to game with them like it doesn't matter.
"You know who you associate yourself with is very important."
And  then Summit reacted by doing a full stream without interacting with his chat at all.
"Everyone's jumping down my throat about playing some games with Jake Paul.
and it's just like, what did you guys want me to do?"
"He DMs me and says, "Hey man your stream's dope dude."
What do you want me to be like, "Don't talk to me! I f*cking hate you you're a sh*tty human being."
Since that fateful April stream Summit’s viewership has taken a bit of a dip.
He was averaging almost 20k viewers in April, dipped to just over 16k in May and then just
over 14k in July.
It took a long time for esports to be taken seriously in the mainstream.
And it’s for that reason that its fans can be critical of their heros.
They want consistency, absolute undenying passion and loyalty.
"Oh esports ready, oh my f*cking goodness dude."
With that said, fans of Summit have historically been pretty hard on their favourite streamer.
He often seems to be on the butt of their jokes.
Even back in 2016, Summit was swatted by his own chat
while mobile streaming himself playing Pokemon GO in a park.
"I was holding my hands up, I wasn't gonna make a move. You know I wasn't going to go turn my stream
off with one hand you know. I was a little nervous, I mean you got guys pointing rifles at you,
they weren't pistols, they were rifles."
Recently, he 's
admitted that he’s developed a lot of anxiety around streaming
And that going live, has become a taxing and overwhelming process:
"Coming in here in front of you guys, it's the hardest thing I've had to do in a long time.
I know I've done this for years, and it just doesn't make sense to me why
why it's scary to get on, why it's scary to sit here in front of you guys. Why it's scary to talk."
"We're back. I'm hoping that we're here to stay, hopefully we don't have any f*cking problems. I'm feeling healthy."
(Stream)
The old-guard of esports needs somewhere to go and someone to flame.
Somewhere to check out the new Call of Duty game or to get a nice daily dosage of streamer
salt.
And Summit 1G will always be there for that.
(Stream)
Summit1G isn’t the hero or the villain of the streaming world
He’s simply adapting the way he always has.
"To be able to do 10k viewers, 9k viewers, 8k viewers,
playing any game, that's the f*cking dream right there bros."
"You don't need to be slamming 500k a month and sh*t dude.
to be happy, I'm very happy."
As we watch this world grow, there’s more pressure on people like Summit than anyone
else to play hot games like Fortnite or PUBG.
To market themselves the way the likes of Ninja, Shroud and DrDisrespect have been able to.
"Some of you guys are ride or die 1Gs no matter what and I respect that."
To goof-off, to meme and be the five-tool streamer that viewers have come to expect.
(Stream)
Summit was there when it all started on Twitch.
And you better believe he’s going to scrap and claw to stick around now that all eyes
are on that purple icon.
Summit1G isn’t going anywhere.
(Stream)
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.